okay folks i guess we have to talk about
[Music]
clowns
this is jonathan pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Applause]
[Music]
in the past few months there has
appeared let's say on the
horizon of the internet a meme the clown
world meme in fact
the clown world meme has been around for
quite a while but it seems to
have taken on a certain amount of
popularity with
also the resurgence of a clown version
of pepe the frog
and so because i gave you all the
metaphysics of pepe a few years ago with
uh jordan peterson
i figured that i am it's my
responsibility
to give you the metaphysics of clowns i
guess is the way to put it
and to explain this to you
the meaning of clowns is actually very
important to understand
right now at this time i'm going to tell
you right away as i start this
a lot of the insight that i'm getting to
explain this to you is coming
from my brother matthias who wrote a
book on symbolism
called the language of creation and in
that book
you can deduce most of the things that
i'm talking about now
although i don't think he talks
explicitly about clowns he talks about
foolishness
and about costumes and about many of the
things which are related
to understanding what the clown means
and so if you haven't read that yet guys
check that out
and so here we go with the understanding
of the clown
now in order to understand the
importance of
clowns we have to kind of back up and
start at uh
something more broad we could call it
is to understand the meaning of
carnivals
now when i talk about carnivals what i'm
referring to
are we could call them um
feast of excess or inversion rituals
inversion
festivals those these festivals exist in
almost every single culture
in one way or the other sometimes as
particular festivals
other times also as figures who are part
of the life of
communities and um and in the west we
can find the meaning of
the carnival in its word carnival means
the
feast of flesh it is actually referring
to
the the time just before lent which is
fat tuesday in the uh
catholic tradition and then also meat
fair which is
a direct translation of carnival
in the orthodox tradition and so in the
time just before lent
we have this meat fair this carnival
which is the last moments in which we
can eat flesh it is
the feast of flesh and so you can
understand that in that moment
it also becomes a moment of
the more traditional things we think
about when we think about
a carnival so what do we think about
when we think about a carnival
we think of upside down behavior
or excessive behavior garish costumes
just the idea of wearing a costume
itself wearing a mask
hiding yourself uh projecting some
uh some grotesque figure some funny
figure
um in the carnival there's also this
notion of
noise making noise making and
and also acrobatics all of this imagery
that comes with the festival garish
behavior also sometimes inappropriate
behavior
the uh you know something which verges
on uh
sexual behavior as well of course that
today in the modern carnivals
has been taken to the extremes where
where the
you know near new dancing and uh all
this inverted behavior extremely
lewd behavior has kind of taken over the
carnival
um but even traditionally even christian
carnivals had probably hints of that
that were laid in there are other
carnivals in
medieval tradition there is for example
a
feast which was called the feast of the
ass and in
that feast it happened um celebrating
the
flight into egypt after christmas and it
also always came around
you know around new year's day and so
the feast of the ass
in that festival they would actually
walk
a donkey with a woman on the back of the
donkey and a child
they would walk the donkey into the
church all the way up to the altar
and then while the donkey was in the
altar
at the end of the mass instead of saying
the final words of the mass
the priest and the people in the church
would pray like a donkey would make hee
ha
sounds like a donkey another
feast which is similar to the to the
that which is in the spirit of the
carnival
and in the spirit of the feast of the
ass is what was called the feast of
fools and this happened
at the circumcision of christ and uh
the feast of fools was uh was a once
again an upside down
uh feast where they would elect a lord
of misrule
or a a foolish bishop a fake bishop
that would act upside down and and do
everything upside down from what a
bishop does and
and make fun of the ecclesiastical
office now
of course these um these traditions were
often
condemned by the church especially later
after the middle ages
they were vehemently condemned by the
church who wanted to kind of straighten
things out
but it's important to understand some
it's important to understand
why those festivals came about kind of
what they can mean
and uh what their implications are to
understand
the uh this this upside down behavior
this carnivalesque
behavior one of the things to understand
is to understand
the basic cycle of existence we need to
remind ourselves of this basic
cycle of resi of existence which is you
know the day
you work and then in the night you sleep
you go back
into this chaotic state you know during
the
the week in the in the biblical week
there is the week
and then at the end there's the sabbath
which is the time where
things stop to be productive and start
to rest we have
also the same thing with the jubilee so
you have these cycles
where at the end of the cycles you also
have
these moments where things where logic
is no longer
what is holding the world together there
is this notion of a little death
or a little sleep and you could call it
a little
chaos now if you look at the the mardi
gras
festivals when you look at the symbolism
you can understand
how it works and so just as we get
towards
lent we have this excess we have this
moment
of inversion of upside downness and
then what we have is uh in the western
tradition we have
ash wednesday and on ash wednesday it is
a moment to remind us of our mortality
where people receive crosses of ash that
are from the
the cycle the past cycles palms for palm
sunday which are burnt
and the ash is made of that and they put
it on people's foreheads
and so there is a
from the excess we have this re
remembrance of death and also
remembrance of residue
of the fact that we are we go back to
dust the fact that we
also will break down and become dust
now that is very important in
understanding that cycle
in the orthodox tradition for example
the day the very day
of meat fair is at the same time the
celebration
of the last judgment the remembrance of
the last judgment
and so in that moment of carnival
is also linked to this idea of the
end and so the end of our life in terms
of
of fat tuesday going into ash wednesday
and then the
end of our the end of
of everything when we think of the last
judgment
and so to understand
understand that as well we have to
understand the amount
that death the cycle of of death
is a cycle where things break down into
their constituent parts where we
decompose
a good place in the bible to see a
meditation on that
is of course in the book of kohelet in
the book of ecclesiastes
where according to tradition king
solomon wrote
at the end of his life where he had
reached
the the um the the height of his reign
and then started to tumble into
different
excesses and in that tumbling into
excess you could say
he comes to the understanding you could
call it the understanding of a holy fool
the understanding that things fall apart
the understanding
that that the world is this cycle
the world is this turning thing and
falling
let's say giving himself up or realizing
this the the cycleness of the cycleness
that's not a word
the cycle of existence and uh and how
things
go up go down how different things
happen in different times and so it is
a kind of understanding of the
vicissitudes of time
where time eats away at space
time eats away at stability and breaks
it down
of course like i said if you've read
matthew's book you will you will
understand
more about that i don't want to go too
much into that particular
sphere but i just want you to see the
relationship of this
of this vanity of vanities everything in
his vanity
in uh you know in the version of uh that
simon and garfunkel did of
the um the ecclesiastes where they
talk about wherever in everything uh
turn
turn turn there is a season turn turn
and so
this idea of turning and turning and
turning um
this is represented in the uh the middle
ages and in
in a classical um tradition as
the notion of the wheel of fortune where
the the
the world is this cycle this wheel where
if you're up today you're down tomorrow
and there's no accounting for this
turning you know nothing is stable
nothing is permanent
everything breaks down and so it makes
sense to understand
how these carnivals appear at these
moments
in which things are getting ready to
break down
or a connection with the carnival
and the margin so for example i told you
about the festival of the ass
well the festival of the ass is christ
fleeing
the the israel and finding refuge in a
foreign land and so
it is this upside down world where he is
leaving his own land which has become
dangerous
and finding refuge in the foreign
egyptian land
where the hebrews were once slaves and
so
that going into egypt is moving into
that
upside down world where you know you you
become
a you you become a slave to the
foreigner of course christ does not
become a slave to the foreigner that's a
different story
but moving out towards egypt is
repeating that pattern
of how the hebrews went into and to
egypt as well
and in terms of the feast of the
circumcision it's a little more
complicated
but let's just say that it is like
the last judgment you could call the
feast of circumcision
the moment where the periphery is
actually cut off
and so just at that moment when the
periphery
is cut off there is this kind of
celebration of the
periphery and then we cut off the flesh
we cut off the
carnival we cut off the the carnal part
of the
of the body just like from um
fat tuesday to lent we cut off the meat
okay and so all of this is
is totally coherent even though these
festivals were
like i said often uh criticized by the
uh
the um church authorities nonetheless
they are
very coherent in the way what they're
talking about now in
in um in judaism it's it's quite
interesting as well because they also
have a feast like this which is the
feast of purim
and in the feast of purim they are
celebrating the story of esther
now if you listen to what i said before
you will see a resemblance
in the story of esther queen esther
is a queen in a foreign land
and she is married to the king but the
king does not know she is jewish
it's a secret there's a there's this
secret element to
her identity or her identity is hidden
uh in that situation and in the book of
esther
as well the name of god does not appear
in fact god is absent
from the book of esther and so you can
imagine it as this moment
at the end where things are upside down
and that god does not seem to be hidden
as well god is not
appearing in the in the manifest world
it looks like there's this disjunct
between
between the will of god you could say
and the way that the world is
laying itself out but then in the story
of purim there is
this moment of of uncertainty where
there
is on one hand someone who wants to kill
the jews
and uh and you don't know what's going
to happen you don't know how it's going
to end
and then finally at the very end it
flips
and and the jews are blessed and the
ones who wanted to kill the jews
are put to death and so i've often told
you about this double
inversion and so the story of esther is
the perfect example
of this double inversion where the world
has been turned
upside down and now the the people of
god are
under attack are going to be killed and
in the last moment
through the revelation of some secret
then things
flip back and the curse falls on the
blast and the blessed
blessing falls on the curse and so the
jews even today
there's a there's a talmudic law which
says that
on purim you must drink until
you are so drunk that you cannot tell
the difference between
the blessing for mordecai and the curse
of haman
which means that you know haman was the
one who wanted to kill the the jews and
mordecai was
the the jewish leader who then received
the blessing so this idea that you must
put yourself in a state where you can no
longer tell between your left and your
right hand
where you can no longer tell between the
a curse and a blessing
you must kind of put yourself in a
moment of
absolute chaos and the festival of purim
is also called
the festival of lots which is related to
that
this notion of um of
of games of chance you could call it
games
games where you don't know what the
result is going to be now first of all
even the notion of games is important to
understand in terms of the carnival if i
say carnival and games
obviously you can see the connection if
i say carnival and i say games of chance
you can probably also see the connection
think of places like las vegas
think of uh the aesthetics of the of the
casino and the showgirls and the
and the entertainment and all of that
which is related to
uh to the world of let's say games of
chance
as we reach let's say the end of a cycle
as we
we go into entertainment mode for uh
for a um for a moment now of course
today we we don't have we don't we do
celebrate a little bit of mardi gras
people do celebrate um
you know fat tuesday but we mostly have
our inversion
rituals are there we can't you can't get
rid of them if you try to get rid of
inversion rituals they come back
because they're important in helping
mark the end
because you need to be able to see a
little bit of the opposite
in order to know what the center is you
need to be able to experience or to
to to to see what inverted behavior
is and so you can imagine in virgin
festivals as a kind of uh
as a kind of little um imagine like a a
world where
we have this this chaotic tendency and
if you just bottle it up if you try to
make a system which contains
all of our chaotic tendencies it's just
going to it's just going to boil up it's
just going to accumulate accumulate
accumulate
until it explodes but if you have a
little valve
and then every every year every
uh certain amount of time you let out a
little bit of uh
of chaos then what it does is it pres
it prevents the the people from going
into
a full chaos state and it is
particular to understand that after the
middle ages
as the enlightenment arrived some of the
things that they did was to outlaw
all these festivals to outlaw all the
carnival-esque festivals especially in
protestant countries
these were extremely frowned upon and
you can just see today
you know how certain types of
protestants oppose
halloween so much because the the
they can see that it is an inversion
festival and they're right to see it
but they want the whole world to be able
to be contained
in in their thing they don't they don't
they don't understand the m that the
monsters need to
continue to exist on the margins that
you can't totally get rid of them or
that if you get rid of the monsters
on the margins there are bigger monsters
behind them that you didn't know but
those little monsters were protecting
you from
so you keep getting rid of those
monsters all you get are bigger monsters
so in our society we don't have the the
carnival so much what we have
is some things that have embodied the
aesthetic of the carnival
the idea of the carnival is of course
the the county fair or the fairs the
circus the traveling circuses
the traveling fairs and those really if
you want to
see a cultural phenomena that has
mythological implications
um because our world is has gone
moved away from the center a place to
look at something which still has a
a kind of mythological form it is these
county fairs
uh and and i don't say that to
necessarily uh
to praise these fairs i say it just as a
matter of fact
that if you look at what the fairs look
like you can see
understand you know what the carnival is
and what it means to be
at the end near death at the at the edge
of uh
of a cycle you could call it and so
the the county fair one of the things
that it has of course is you can imagine
it as a microcosm
just like everything is somewhat of a
microcosm but you can imagine it as a
microcosm
from the perception of the of the
periphery from the perception of the
edge right
and so what are the things that you see
at a
fair first of all you see a lot of
spinning
everything is spinning the ferris wheel
all these different rides that are
spinning the the carousel
with these animals that are spinning
around and around and around
go round and round every if you want to
see this going round and round
this pointless turning or you could call
this this entertaining
this is entertainment turning where you
go around
in circles in order to amuse yourself
this is taken to extremes of course
in our in our amusement parks and our in
our affairs in our
you know in our circus uh let's say the
circus aesthetic
and so the rides are part of that but
also if you
go to a circus for example that's where
you see the most
of it you see a lot of spinning in terms
of acrobatics flying through the air
turning and turning and turning and
we're
getting to it the ultimate example of
this
the highest let's say purest most
distilled
version of this is of course the
clown now
we need to actually analyze the clown
because a clown is
is that contradictory figure of the edge
to it to an extent that is hard to fully
describe first of all you can know this
by the fact
that everything the clown does is
exaggerated
everything that the clown does is in a
way a parody
of an actual action the clown wears
clothes that does not fit shoes that are
too big
pants that are too big not fitting is
is part of the entire aesthetic of the
clown
too many clowns in a car uh you know
all of these things that clowns do all
of these types of jokes
falling down making someone fall down
the whole idea of
accidental anything is this breakdown of
meeting an accident
is a breakdown of meaning so falling
down making someone fall down
the other aspect is for example
something as simple as the pie in the
face
now a pie
a pie is imagine a pie like the world
okay
imagine that the pie is the world i know
this is going to stretch you guys a
little too much
but the pie is a bowl and in the bowl is
food so imagine
it's the potentiality of the world right
we get our food from the
from the earth we get our food from
nature so imagine this is the world it's
this bowl
and in it is a is a is a pie and then
what are you supposed to do with a pie
right you're supposed to eat it but then
you don't eat it
you take it in the face right you cover
you
you get covered in pie it could be
all kinds of other things that you can
cover yourself with
but the pie is the particular one
because it's food that you're supposed
to eat in order to integrate into your
body
and make it part of yourself but instead
of that it becomes a
it becomes something that you are that
you're assaulted with and it
and you beca and it makes you silly it
uh it becomes a way
to humiliate you okay and so the pie in
the face
is of course uh part of that another
aspect of the
carnival or the fair that i that i
forgot to mention
is of course the the games now the games
are important at the festival because
the games are always trying to hit
a center from far away so you're
standing far away
trying to hit a dart in something you're
trying to shoot
at at something you're trying to get a
ring to go around a bottle
all of these are the same image right
this distance from the center trying to
get it and obviously
in carnival games we all know that most
of the carnival games are rigged
and you can pretty much never really
succeed or so rarely
that you know you end up spending more
money on the game
than um then you could ever win and so
understanding that is also part of this
kind of upside down
carnival uh clown world now
another aspect is of course the noise
making
you know this honk honk this is this is
exactly
accidental noises honk honk this is
a symbol a symbol of the breakdown in
meaning
imagine someone who's speaking and you
interrupt them with what honk honk
imagine they're trying to say it's honk
honk this is exactly
the interruption the eruption of chaos
into
into uh in a normal uh situation i mean
the clown of course that's what
the the clown is in general the clown
is also a lot funnier when faced with a
straight person with a normal
person when they go up to them and then
you know they make fools
of the other people then they end up
making fools of themselves
all of that is part of this topsy-turvy
uh upside down world another aspect
is the capacity or the trying to balance
yourself on something
now the ultimate image of is that of
course rolling
on a ball uh you know walking on a
high wire but rolling on a ball is one
of the best ones
because it is turning this turning it is
changing it is you know it
is showing this turning this turning
this turning the spinning that i told
you about
in the uh in the carnival and in the
fair and all of that uh in the circus
and it's and it's uh it's bringing it
into this idea almost of standing on top
of the world
and somehow making light of this
spinning you know
being in a certain manner above it
because you're aware of it
you know and this is this is really
where i come to what i could call the uh
the uh the possible redeeming
aspect of the clown okay now
in several traditions in several
cultures
there are such a thing as holy clowns or
holy fools and the purpose of the holy
clowns and the holy fools
is to show the limit
of your system is to show the mystery
which is that you do not your order your
hierarchy
cannot contain everything and
in by doing that it it actually can
reinforce the hierarchy this is where
it's difficult
sometimes for people to understand
because you could see the clown as being
a subversive figure
as as a figure that is there to
poke at the hierarchy and and invert it
you know put it upside down
make fun of it mock it and yes that is
possible
but by embodying the inversion
in a conscious manner and by showing
the limit of the hierarchy what it's
doing
is one pointing to the mystery pointing
to the fact that there's a higher
mystery
that is higher than your rules that is
higher than your conventions
that is higher than all that but then
also reinforcing
those conventions as well by showing
their
limit where they pass into unacceptable
behavior
and that can be done consciously many of
the holy fools in the christian
tradition
were would actually sometimes pretend to
be insane
which sometimes pretend to be uh
mentally ill
in order to to bring out let's say
the limits of people's uh behavior and
to show
the the limits of their behavior in
native american cultures for example in
uh
in the lakota tribe there are certain
figures which are called hayoka
and they are they could call them holy
clowns and their purpose
is to to do the opposite
you know to uh to pretend when that
they're full when there's no food
to uh to make potty noises to fart
during rituals to show the exception to
kind of
show the limit of the order of what is
happening
and this is is it participates in the
totality you could say of the story
it's the same thing that we had in the
west with jesters jesters
played that role in the king's court
which is that the king
might tend to be to feel like his
hierarchical authority is
self-sufficient
that it has that it is completely uh
right
um but the jester was there because of
his role as a nothing because of his
role as a
as a fool he was able to actually point
out
certain things which were uh
which could be embarrassing to the king
certain things certain truths about the
king which the king did not want to
reveal
certain secrets that the king didn't
want people to know that could be
embarrassing to himself
he the jester was allowed to mention
them and
tell them because he was outside of the
system you could say
and everybody knew that that was the
role that the jester
played um now
we see the same for example in the story
of king david
king david there is a moment in king
david's story where
he is in the foreign land he's in the
kingdom of gath
and so he david pretends to be
crazy he drools at the mouth he pretends
to be insane
in order that they they do not recognize
him
as being the king and he is able to
escape the
the foreign the foreign king and so
the thing that we have now this is the
problem with
our situation now with our society right
now
is that what happens when
the carnival is no longer an exception
what happens when the entire world
becomes a carnival
and this is seems to be where we are
right now
we are in this upside down world where
the exception is the rule
where we where the most valued thing is
a comedian
the most valued thing is it is a honk
honk clown
these are the things that we value you
know our
our uh sexual mores are upside down
our you know we we care about uh
money more than we care about spiritual
things we everything
about our society is topsy-turvy and
upside down
and so in a certain manner this
is possibly the ultimate
meaning of the clown this is
possibly the ultimate possibility of the
clown
i told you many times about the double
inversion
what happens when everything is upside
down
if the clown's purpose is to show
is to turn things upside down that is
the purpose of the clown
what happens when things are already
upside down
well possibly the clown is there to put
things back
right side up and so if for example
certain symbols like the rainbow
symbol has been taken you know
to represent certain values and
certain morality of exception certain
exceptional
sexual behaviors and this has become a
way to
praise those and to make them the
central tenet of our society
to make them normal to normalize them
well it is possible
that the clown can take that
and flip it into a crown
flip it into a crown of glory just like
the rainbow
itself is this this periphery
where the white light breaks down into
multiplicity of colors
but the rainbow goes the rainbow is
actually a circle
it goes goes down and it goes up you
know
and it is possible to flip that
symbolism
so that you know the circle turns once
more
and puts things back on their feet
and so i hope this this uh description
of clowns and the importance of clowns
and maybe the profound meaning of clowns
today
might uh be helpful to you and so thanks
everybody for your attention and i will
see you soon
if you enjoy the symbolic world content
there's a lot of things you can do to
help us out
if you're not subscribed please do go
ahead and share this to all your friends
if you can get involved in the
discussion we have a facebook group in
which people can talk about these
subjects
i will put all those links in the
description and also if you can please
support us financially by going to my
website www.thesymbala
support and i also have a patreon and a
subscribe star so thanks again and i
will see you soon